the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
talking about principle component
analysis which we essentially introduced
as a way to work with a bunch of data so
we have the data that's given to us when
we want to do PCA is a bunch of vectors
X 1 X M all right so so they're random
vectors in Rd ok and what we mentioned
is that we're gonna be using linear
algebra in particular the spectral
theorem that guarantees to us that if I
look at the covariance matrix of this
guy's or its empirical covariance matrix
since there's symmetric real matrices
and there are positive semi-definite
there exists a diagonalization in two
non negative eigenvalues all right and
so here those things live in Rd so it's
a really large space and what we want to
do is to map it down into a space that
we can visualize hopefully a space of
size 2 or 3 or if not then we're just
gonna take more and start looking at
subspaces all together alright so think
of the case where these large but not
larger than n alright so let's say you
have a large number of points so the
question is is it possible to project
those things onto a lower dimensional
space D prime which is much less than D
so think of G prime of equals say 2 or
or 3 and so that you keep as much
information about the cloud a point that
you had originally all right so again
the example that we could have is that
x1 to xn for say X I for patient I is
recording a bunch of body measurements
and maybe blood pressure some symptoms
etc and then we have a cloud of n
patients and we're trying to visual
maybe to see if we if I could see for
example that there's two groups of
patients maybe I would know that I have
two groups of different disease or maybe
two groups of different patients that
respond differently to a particular
disease or drugs etc alright so
visualizing is going to give us quite a
bit of insight about what this the
spatial arrangement of those vectors are
and so pc8 says well you know here of
course in this question one thing is not
define is what is information and we
said that one thing we might want to do
when we project is that points start to
not collide with each other and so that
means we're trying to find directions
where after I project the puns are still
pretty spread out and so I can see
what's going on and pca says okay so
there's many ways to answer this
question and PCA says let's just find a
a subspace of dimension D prime that
keeps as much covariant structure as
possible and and the reason is that
those directions are the ones that
maximize the variance which is a proxy
for the spread there's many many ways to
do this there's actually a Google video
that was released maybe last week about
the data visualization team of Google
that shows you something called tiffni
which is essentially something that
tries to do that it takes points in
their high dimensions and tries to map
them in lower dimension so that you can
actually visualize them and tiffni
is some alternative to pca that gives
another definition for the word
information alright I'll talk about this
towards the end how you can actually
somewhat automatically extend everything
we've said for PCA to an infinite family
of procedures alright so how do we do
this well the way we do this is as
follows right so remember given those
guys we can form something which is
called s which is the sample or the
empirical
covariance matrix okay and since from
couple slides ago we know that S has
this the eigenvalue decomposition s is
equal to PD P transpose where P is
orthogonal okay so that's where we used
our linear algebra result so that means
that P transpose P is equal to P track
PP transpose which is the identity okay
so remember s is a d by D matrix right
and so P is also D by D and D is
diagonal and and I'm actually gonna take
without loss of generality I'm going to
assume that D so it's gonna be diagonal
and I'm gonna have something that looks
like lambda 1 ya lambda 1 to lambda D
those are called the eigenvalues of s
what we know is that the lambda J's are
now negative and actually what I'm gonna
assume without loss of generality is
lambda 1 is larger than lambda 2 which
is larger then lambda D okay because in
particular does the composition the
spectral decomposition is not entirely
unique I could permute the columns of P
and I would still have an orthogonal
matrix and to balance that I would also
have to permute the entries of D okay so
there's as many the compositions as
their permutations right so there's
actually quite a bit but the bag of
eigenvalues is unique right if I keep
the set of eigen values is unique the
ordering is certainly not unique okay so
here I'm just gonna pick I'm gonna nail
down one particular permutation actually
maybe two in case in case I have
equalities but let's say there's let's
say I pick one that satisfies this and
the reason why I do this is really not
very important is just to say when I
talk I'm gonna want to talk about the
largest of those eigen values so it's
just gonna be easier for me to say that
this one is lambda 1 rather and
than the seven all right so this is just
to say that the largest eigenvalue ms is
lambda one okay if i didn't do that that
would just call it maybe lambda max and
you would just know which one I'm
talking about
all right so so what's happening now is
that if I look at D then it turns out
that if I start so if I do P transpose X
I I am actually projecting my X eyes and
basically changing the basis for my X
eyes and now these the empirical
covariance matrix of those guys all
right so let's check that so what it
means is that if I look at so what I
claim is that P transpose X I that's a
new vector let's call it Y I it's equal
it's also in Rd and when I claim is that
the covariance matrix of this guy is
actually now this diagonal matrix which
means in particular that if they were
Gaussian then they would be independent
but I need I also know now that there's
no correlation across coordinates of Y I
okay so to prove this let me assume that
X bar is equal to zero and the reason
why I do this is because it's just
annoying to carry out all the centering
constantly when I talk about this
alright so when X bar is equal to zero
that implies that SS is very simple form
it's of the form sum from I equal 1 to N
of X I X I transpose right so that's my
s but what I want is the s of Y so ok
that implies also that P times X bar
which is equal to P times X bar is also
equal to 0 right so that means that Y
bar
why has been 0 if this is 0 so if I look
at the sample covariance matrix of Y
it's just going to be something that
looks like the sum of the outer products
or the why I why I transpose okay and
again the reason why I make this
assumption so that I don't have to write
minus X bar X bar transpose but you can
do it and it's gonna work exactly the
same all right so now I look at this s
prime and so what is this s prime well
I'm just going to replace Y I with PXI
right so it's the sum from I equal 1 to
N of px I px I transpose which is equal
to the sum from sorry there's a 1 over N
so it's equal to 1 over n sum from I
equal 1 to n of P X I X I transpose P
transpose agree I just said that the
transpose of a B is the transpose of B
times the transpose of a and so now I
can push the sum in right p does not
depend on I so this thing here is equal
to P as P transpose because the sum of
the xixi transpose divided by n is s but
what is P s P transpose well we know
that P that s sorry is equal to sorry
that's P transpose right so this was
with a P transpose that sorry I made a
an important mistake here so why is p
transpose X I so this is P transpose and
P transpose here which means that this
is P transpose and this is double
transpose which is just nothing and that
transpose and nothing ok so now I write
s as P D P transpose that's the spectral
decomposition that I had before this by
eigen value composition which means that
now if I look at s prime its P
transpose times P D P transpose P but
now P transpose P is the identity P
transpose P is the identity so this is
actually just equal to D okay
and again you can check that this also
works if you have to Center all those
guys as you go but if you think about it
this is the same thing as saying that I
just replace X I by X I minus X bar and
then it's true that Y bar is also the P
times X I minus X bar all right so now
we have that D is the empirical
covariance matrix of those guys the Y
eyes which are P transpose X eyes and so
in particular what it means is that if I
look at the covariance of Y say J Y K
right so that's the covariance of the
jate coordinate of Y and the Keith
coordinate of Y I'm just not putting an
index but maybe let's see the first one
or something like this any of them at
their iid then what is this covariance
is actually 0 if J is different from K
and the covariance between y J and YJ
which is just the variance of YJ is
equal to lambda J the J's largest
eigenvalue okay so the eigen values
capture the variance of my observations
in this new coordinate system and
they're completely orthogonal so what
does that mean well again remember if I
chop off the head of my of my Gaussian
in multi-dimensions we said that what we
started from was something that looked
like this right and we said well there's
one direction that's important that this
guy in one important that this guy when
I apply the transformation P transpose
what I'm doing is then realigning this
thing with the new axis or in a way
rather to be fair I'm not actually
realigning the I'm not really realigning
the
ellipses with the axes I'm really
realigning the axes with the
right so really what I'm doing is I'm
saying after I apply P I'm just rotating
this coordinate system so now it becomes
this guy okay and now my ellipse is
actually completely aligned and and and
what happens here is that this
coordinate is independent of that
coordinate and that's what we write here
okay if they're Gaussian I didn't really
tell you this I'm only making statements
about covariances if they're Gaussian
those imply statements about
independence okay so as I said the
variance now lambda 1 is actually the
variance of p transpose X I but if I
look now I D so this is a vector so I
need to look at the first coordinate of
this guy right so it turns out that
doing this is actually the same thing as
looking at the variance of what well the
first column of P times X I right so
that's the variance of the I'm gonna
call it V 1 transpose X I where P
so the V 1 V D in our D our eigenvectors
and each VI is associated to lambda I
okay so that's what we saw when we
talked about this again you can position
a couple of slides back that's the one
here okay so if I call the columns of P
V 1 to V D this is what's happening okay
so when I look at lambda 1 it's just a
variance of X I in a product with D 1
and we made this picture right when we
said well let's say V 1 is here and then
X 1 is here and if V 1 has the as a unit
norm then the inner product between X I
and V 1 is just the length of this guy
here right so that's the variance of the
X I says the length of X I so this is 0
that's the length of X I when I project
it onto the direction that spanned by V
1 if you wanna has links to this is
really just twice this link if yang V V
is like three it's three times this but
it turns out that since P satisfies P
transpose P is equal to the identity
that's an orthogonal matrix that's right
here then this actually implies this is
actually saying the same thing as VI
transpose or VJ transpose V J which is
really the norm squared of V J is equal
to 1 and VJ transpose VK is equal to 0
if J is different from K okay the
eigenvectors are orthogonal to each
other and they're actually all of normal
one
so now I know that this is indeed a
direction and so when I look about I
look at V one time if transpose X I am
really measuring exactly this length and
that's what is this length says the
length of the projection of X I onto
this line that's the line that spanned
by v1 so if I had a very high
dimensional problem and I started to
look at the direction v1 let's say v1
now is not a I get vector its any
direction then if I start if I want to
do this low dimensional projection then
I have to understand how the excise
project onto the line that spanned by
any one because this is all all that I'm
going to be keeping at the end of the
day about my excise so what we want is
to find the direction where those excise
those projections have a lot of variance
and we know that the variance of X I on
this direction is actually exactly given
by lambda 1 okay so sorry that's the
empirical here yeah I should call it
variance hat that's the empirical
variance everything is empirical here
we're talking about the empirical
covariance matrix all right and so in
pity I have that lambda 2 is the
empirical variance of when I project X I
onto V 2 which is the second one all
right just for exactly this reason
okay any question
all right so lambda J's are gonna be
important for us right lambda G measure
the spread of the points when I project
them onto a line which is a
one-dimensional space right and so I'm
gonna have let's say I want to pick only
one I'm going to have to find a one
dimensional space that carries the most
variants and and I claim that v1 is the
one that actually does that maximizes
the spread okay so the claim so for any
direction u in Rd and by direction I
really just mean that the norm of U is
equal to one okay I need to play fair
I'm gonna compare myself to other things
of length one so I need to play fair and
look at directions of length one now if
I'm interested in the empirical variance
of x1 transpose sorry u transpose x1 u
transpose xn then this thing is
maximized for u equals V 1 where V 1 is
the eigenvector associated to lambda 1
and lambda 1 is not any eigen values the
largest of all those all right this is
the largest eigenvalue so why is that -
well there's also a claim is that for
any direction u so that's 1 & 2 the
variance of U transpose X now this is
just a random variable and I'm looking
about the true variance this is
maximized maximized
for you equals let's call it W 1 where W
1 is the eigenvector of Sigma now I'm
talking about the true variance whereas
here we're talking about the empirical
variance so the true variance is the
eigenvectors of the true Sigma
associated to the largest eigen value of
Sigma so I did not give it a name here
that was lambda 1 for the empirical 1
for the true one you can give it another
name you one if you want but that's just
that's just the same thing all it's
saying is like wherever I see empirical
I can remove it ok so why is this claim
true well let's look at the second one
for example so what is the variance of U
transpose X right so that's what I want
to know so that's the expectation so
let's assume that X is 0 again for some
reasons as before so what is the
variance is just the expectation of the
square right all right I just need to
not only to remove the expectation and
the expectation of the square is just
the expectation of U transpose X and
then I'm going to write the other one X
transpose u ok and we know that this is
deterministic so I'm just going to take
that this is just u transpose
expectation of X X transpose u
and what is this guy this covariance
Sigma right that's just what Sigma is so
the variance I can write as u transpose
Sigma u we've made this computation
before and now what I want to claim is
that this thing is actually less than
the largest eigenvalue which I actually
called lambda 1 here I should probably
not and the piece ok ok so okay let's
just pretend everything is uh is not
empirical all right so now I'm gonna
write Sigma as P lambda 1 lambda n P
transpose that's just the eigen
decomposition where I admittedly reuse
the same notation as I did for s so I
should really put some Prime's
everywhere so you know those are things
that are actually different in practice
right so this is just the decomposition
of Sigma you seem confused how are you a
question yeah
so okay so I can make everything I'm
saying I can talk about either the
variance or the empirical variance and
you can just add the word empirical in
front of it whenever you want the same
thing works but just for the sake of
removing the confusion let's just do it
again with let's just do it again with s
all right so I'm just gonna do
everything with s so I'm gonna assume
that X bar is equal to zero and here I'm
going to talk about the empirical
variance which is just 1 over n sum from
I equal 1 to N of U transpose X I
squared so it's the same thing
everywhere you see an expectation you
just put an average right okay and then
I get 1 over N sum from I equal 1 to N
of X I X I transpose and now I'm gonna
call this guy s ok because that's what
it is so this is u transpose su but just
the fact that I could just replace the
expectation by averages everywhere you
can tell that the thing is gonna work
for either one or the other so now this
thing was actually so now I don't have
any problem with my notation this is
actually the decomposition of s that's
the spectral decomposition in its doings
eigen values and so now what I have is
that when I look at you transpose su and
this is actually equal to PU transpose s
PU ok there's a transpose somewhere
that's this guy and that's this guy okay
now I'm sorry that's not P that's D lets
me write that's this diagonal matrix
okay let's look at this thing and let's
call P transpose u let's call it B okay
so that's also a vector in Rd what is it
is just I take a unit vector and then I
apply P transpose to it so that's
basically what happens to a unit vector
when I apply the same change of basis
that I did all right so I'm just
changing my mice my animal system and I
just with the same way I did for the
other ones so what's happening when I
write this well now I have that u
transpose su is B transpose D B but now
doing B transpose DB when D is diagonal
and B is the vector is a very simple
thing right I can expand it this is what
this is just the sum from J equal 1 to D
of lambda J be J squared right so that's
just like matrix vector multiplication
and in particular I know that the
largest of those guys is lambda 1 and
those guys are all non-negative so this
thing is actually less than lambda 1
times the sum from J equal 1 to D of
lambda J squared sorry BJ squared and
this is just the norm of B squared so if
I want to prove what's on the slide all
I need to check is that B has a norm
which is at most one it's gonna be at
most one why well because B is really
just a change of basis for you right and
so if I take a vector I'm just changing
its basis I'm certainly not changing its
length think of a rotation and I can
also flip it but think of a rotation and
so now well actually four vector is just
gonna
and so now what I have I just have to
check that the norm of B squared is
equal to what well it's equal to the
norm of P transpose u squared which is
equal to u transpose P P transpose u but
P there's two colonel so this thing is
actually just the identity so that's
just u transpose U which is equal to the
norm u squared which is equal to one
because I took you to have normal one in
the first place and so this your rate
was actually of norm equal to one I just
need to have it less but it's equal and
so what I'm left with is that this thing
is actually equal to lambda1 so I know
that for every u that I pick so that has
norm
right so I'm just reminding you that you
here is norm squared equal to one for
every new that I pick this u transpose
su is at most lambda one right so that's
the u transpose su is at most lambda one
and we know that that's the variance
that's the empirical variance when I
project my points onto Direction spanned
by you so now I have an empirical
variance which is that most lambda one
but I also know that if I take you to be
anything very something very specific at
many ways on the previous board if I
take u to be equal to V 1 then this
thing is actually not an inequality this
is an equality and the reason is when I
actually take you to be V 1 all of this
BJ's are going to be 0 except for the
one that's B 1 which is itself equal to
1 ok so I mean we can briefly check this
but if I take V if
U is equal to v1 so what I have is that
u transpose su is equal to the sum sorry
is equal to P transpose V 1d p transpose
B 1 of v1 but what is P transpose V 1
well remember P transpose is just a
vector it's just a matrix that has
vectors V 1 transpose here V 2 transpose
here all the way to VD transpose here
and we know that when I take VJ
transpose VK I get 0 if J is different
from K and if I if J is equal to K I get
one okay so P transpose V 1 is equal to
what
so take v1 here and multiply it so when
I the first coordinate is going to be V
1 transpose V 1 which is 1 the second
coordinate is going to be V 2 transpose
V 1 which is 0 and so I get zeros all
the way right so that means that this
thing here is really just the vector 1 0
0 0 and here this is just the vector 1 0
0 0 so when I multiply it with this guy
I'm only picking up the the the top left
element of D which is lambda 1 so for
every one it's less than lambda 1 and
for V 1 it's equal to lambda 1 which
means that it's maximized for a equals V
1 and that's where I said that this is
the fanciest non-convex problem we know
how to solve this was a problem that was
definitely non convex we're maximizing a
convex function of our sphere but we
know that V 1 which is something I mean
of course you still have to believe me
that you can compute the spectral
decomposition efficiently but
essentially if you've taken in linear
algebra you know how that you can
diagonalize a matrix and so you get that
V 1 is just the maximum so you can find
your maximum just by looking at the
spectral decomposition you don't have to
do any optimization or anything like
this
alright so let's recap where are we
we've established that if I start with
my empirical covariance matrix I can
diagonalize it and P transpose sorry P
DP transpose and then if I take the
eigenvector associated to the largest
eigenvalue so if i permute the columns
of P in such a way and and of these in
such a way that they're ordered from the
largest to the smallest when I look at
the diagonal elements of D then if I
pick the first column of P it's V 1 and
V 1 is the distance is the is the
direction on which if I project my
points they're gonna carry the most
empirical variance well that's a good
way if I told you pick one direction on
which along which if you were to project
your points that would be as spread at a
spa
that's probably the one you would pick
and so that's exactly what PCA is doing
for us it says okay if you ask me to
take D prime equal to one I will take v1
just the direction I will just take the
direction that's spanned by v1 and
that's just when I come back to this
picture that was here before this is v1
of course here I have only the only I
have two of them so v2 has to be this
guy or this guy or I mean or this thing
right I mean I don't know them up to
sign so but then if I have three you
know I think of like an olive in three
dimensions then maybe I have one
direction that's slightly more elongated
than the other one and so I'm gonna pick
the second one and so the procedure is
to say well first I'm gonna pick v1 the
same way I picked I picked them on the
first place so the first direction I'm
taking is the leading eigenvector and
then I'm looking for a direction well if
I found one the one I'm gonna want to
find if you say you can take D equal two
you're gonna need a basis for this guy
so the second one has to be orthogonal
to the first one you've already picked
and so the second one you pick is the
one that's just among all those that are
thuggin all 2v1 maximize the empirical
variance when you project onto it and it
turns out that this is actually exactly
v2 you don't have to redo anything again
you're eigendecomposition this is just
the second column of P clearly v2 is our
signal to v1 right we just used it here
this zero here just says that's v2 is
either gonna to v1 right so they're like
this and now what I said what this slide
tells you extra is that v2 among all
those directions that are orthogonal I
mean there's still D minus one of them
this is the one that maximizes the se
residual empirical variance the one that
was not explained by the first Direction
that you picked and you can check that I
mean it's becoming a bit more cumbersome
to write down but you can check that if
you're not convinced please
you're concerned I mean basically one
way to view this is to I mean you're not
really dropping a coordinate because V
one is not a coordinate but let's assume
actually for simplicity that V 1 was
actually equal to e 1 that the direction
that carries the most variance is the
one that just says just look at the
first coordinate of X right so if that
was the case then clearly they're
several directions are the one that
comprise of only of the coordinates two
to D so you could actually just drop the
first coordinate and do the same thing
on a slightly shorter vector of length D
minus one and then you would just look
at the largest eigen vector of these
guys etc etc so in a way that's what's
happening except that you rotate it
before you actually do this and that's
exactly what's happening ok so what we
put together here it's essentially three
things one was statistic statistics says
if you won't spread if you want
information you should be looking at
variance the second one was optimization
optimization said well if you want to
maximize spread well you have to
maximize variance in a certain direction
and that means maximizing over the
sphere of vectors that have unique norm
and that's an optimization problem which
actually turned out to be difficult but
then the third thing that we use to
solve this problem with linear algebra
linear algebra said well it looks like
it's a difficult optimization problem
but it turns out that the answer comes
in almost I mean it's not a closed form
but those things are so used that it's
almost a closed form says just pick the
eigenvectors in order of their
associated eigen values from largest to
smallest okay and that's why principal
component analysis has been so popular
and has gained huge amount of traction
since we had computers that were allowed
to compute eigenvalues and eigenvectors
for matrices of gigantic sizes you can
actually do that if I give you I don't
know the this Google video for example
is talking about words
they want you to just say principle
component analysis of words so I give
you all the words in the dictionary and
sorry well you would have to have a
representation for word so it's a little
more difficult but how do I do this
let's say for example pages of a book
okay I want to understand the pages of a
book and all I need to turn it into a
number and a page of a book is basically
the word count right so I just count the
number of time these shows up number of
times and shows up number of time dog
shows up and so that gives me a vector
it's in pretty high dimensions it's as
many dimensions as their word in
dictionary and now I want to visualize
how those pages get together two pages
very similar or not and so what you
would do is essentially just compute the
largest eigen vector of this matrix
maybe the two largest and then project
this into a point okay yeah yeah but
there's many pages in the world it's
probably there's probably more pages in
the world and there's words in the
dictionary okay yeah so of course if
you're in high dimensions and you don't
have enough points it's gonna be clearly
an issue if you have two points then the
leading eigenvector is gonna be just the
line that goes through those two points
okay regardless of what the dimension is
and clearly you're not learning anything
okay so so you have to pick say the K
largest ones if you go all the way
you're just reordering your thing and
you're not actually gaining anything you
start from D and you go to D so at some
point this procedure has to stop and
let's it stops at K now of course you
should ask me a question which is how do
you choose K right so that's of course a
natural question the probably the basic
answer is just pick K equals 3 because
you can actually visualize it but people
what happens if I take K is equal to 4
if I take K is equal to 4 I'm not gonna
be able to plot points in four
dimensions well I could I could add
color or I could you know try to be a
little smart
but it's actually quite difficult and so
what people tend to do if you have four
dimensions they actually do a bunch of
two-dimensional plots right and that's
what a computer a computer is not very
good I mean by default they don't spit
out three dimensional plots so let's say
they want to plot only two dimensional
things so they're gonna take the first
direction so if say v1 v2 let's say you
have three but you want to have only
two-dimensional plot and then it's gonna
do V 1 V 3 and then V 2 V 3
so really you take all three of them but
it's really just showing you all you
know choices of pairs of those guys
right so if you were to keep K is equal
to 5 you would have 5 choose 2 different
plots
ok so this is the actual principal
component algorithm how its implemented
and it's actually fairly simple I mean
looks like there's lots of steps but
really there's only one that's important
so the first one is the input I give you
a bunch of points x1 to xn in D
dimensions ok and the step two is we'll
compute their empirical covariance
matrix s ok the points themselves we
don't really care we care about their
empirical covariance matrix so it's D by
D matrix now I'm going to feed that and
that's where the actual computation
starts happening I'm going to feed that
to something that knows how to
diagonalize this matrix and you have to
trust me if I want to compute the K
largest eigen values and my matrix is d
by D it's gonna take me about k times d
squared operations ok
so if I want only 3 it's 3 times D
square which is about this squares the
time for me it takes to just even read
the matrix Sigma so that's not too bad
so what it's gonna spit out of course is
the diagonal matrix D and those are nice
because they allow me to tell me which
of the coordinates which of the columns
of P which what is the order in which I
should be taking the columns of P but
what's really important to me is V 1 to
V D because those are gonna be the ones
I'm gonna be using to draw those quads
and now I'm gonna say ok I need to
actually choose some set K and I'm gonna
basically
Kate and look only at the first K
columns of P okay once I have those
columns what I want to do is to project
onto the linear span of those columns
and there's actually a needless simple
way to do this which is just take this
matrix P which is really the matrix of
projection onto the linear span of those
K columns and you just take PK transpose
and then you apply this to every single
one of your points okay now PK transpose
p kz what-what is the size of the matrix
p k yeah
so PK is just this matrix I take V 1 and
I stopped at VK well D by K right each
of the column is an eigen vector
it's of dimension D that's just the I
mean that's a vector in the original
space so I have this D by K matrix right
so all it is is if I had my Wow oh I'm
gonna talk in a second about P K
transpose P K transpose is just this guy
where I stopped at the K vector
okay so PK transpose this K by D so now
when I take Y I which is PK transpose X
I I end up with a point which is in K
dimensions I have only ki coordinates so
I took every single one of my original
points X I which I D coordinates and I
turned it into a point that has only K
coordinates particularly I could have K
is equal to 2 this matrix is exactly the
one that projects right if you think
about it for one second this is just the
matrix that says well we actually did
that several times it's the matrix right
so that was this P transpose u that
showed up somewhere right and so that's
just the matrix that take your point X
in say three dimensions and then just
you know projected down to two
dimensions okay and that's just you know
it goes to the closest point in this in
the subspace now here the the the floor
is flat but we have you know we can pick
any subspace we want depending on what
the lambdas are so the lambdas were
important for us to be able to identify
which columns to pick the fact that we
assumed that they were
ordered tells us that we can pick the
first ones if they were not ordered it
would be just a subset of the columns
depending on what the size of the
eigenvalue is so each lay each column is
labeled and so then of course we still
have this question of how do I pick K
right so there's definitely a matter of
convenience maybe two is convenient if
it works for two you don't have to go
any farther but you might want to say
well I originally I did that to actually
keep as much information as possible I
know that the ultimate thing is to keep
as much information which would be TK is
equal to D that's as much information as
you want but that's essentially the same
question about well you know if I want
to compress a JPEG image how much could
you know how much information should I
keep so it's like still visible and so
there's some rules for that but none of
them is actually really a science so
it's really a matter of what you think
is actually tolerable and we're just
going to start replacing this choice by
maybe some another parameter so we're
here we're gonna basically replace K by
alpha and so we're just do stuff so the
first one that people do that is
probably the most popular one
no the most popular one is definitely
take K is equal to two or three because
it's just convenient to visualize the
second most popular one is the scree
plot so the scree plot remember I have
my values lambda J's and I've chosen the
lambda J's to decrease right so the
indices are chosen in such a way that
lambda is a disk resync ssin so I have
lambda one and let's say it's this guy
here and then I have lambda two and it
says this guy here and then I have
lambda three and let's say it's this guy
here I'm the four on the five one the
six and all I care about is that this
thing decreases right the scree plot
says something like this if there's an
inflection point meaning that you can
sort of do something like this and then
something like this you should stop at
three that's what the scree plot tells
you what it's saying in a way is that
the percentage of the marginal increment
of explaining variants that you get
starts to decrease after you pass this
inflection point let's see why I say
this well here what I have so this thing
this ratio that you see there is
actually the percentage of explained
variance okay so what it means is that
if I look at lambda 1 plus lambda K and
then I divide by lambda 1 plus lambda D
well what is this well this lambda 1
plus lambda D is the total amount of
variance that I get in my points right
that's the trace of Sigma okay so that's
the variance in the first Direction the
first plus the variance in the second
Direction plus the variance in the third
direction that's basically all the
variants that I have possible ok now
this is the variance that I kept in the
first Direction this is the variance
that I kept in the second Direction all
the way to the variance that I kept in
the K direction so I know that this
number is always less than or equal to 1
and it's larger than 1 and this is just
the proportion say of variance explained
by V 1 to V K or simply the proportion
of explained variance by my PCA say okay
so now what this thing is telling me
says well if I look at this thing and I
start saying this inflection point it's
saying oh here you're gaining a lot in a
lot of variance and then at some point
you stop gaining a lot in your and your
proportion of explained variance so this
will translate in something where when I
look at this ratio lambda 1 plus lambda
K divided by lambda 1 plus lambda D this
would translate into a function that
would look like this and what it's
telling you it says well maybe you
should stop here because here every time
you add one you don't get as much as you
did before you actually get like smaller
marginal returns okay
so there's explained variance is the is
the numerator of this ratio and the tool
variance is the denominator
those are pretty straightforward terms
that you would want to use for this
alright so if your goal is to do data
visualization okay so why would you take
K larger than two let's say if you take
killer than six you can start to imagine
that you're gonna have six choose two
which starts to be annoying and if you
have K is equal to ten because you know
you could start in dimension 50,000 and
then k equal to ten would be the place
where you have this thing that's a lot
of plots that you would have to show so
it's not always for data visualization
once I've actually done this I've
actually effectively reduced the
dimension of my problem and what I could
do with what I have is do a regression
on those guys the the v1 so I forgot to
tell you why is it called principal
component analysis well the V J's that I
keep v1 to VK are called
principal components and the effectively
act as the summary of my excise right
when I mentioned image compression I
started with a point X I that was D
numbers let's say 50,000 numbers and now
I'm saying actually you can throw out
those 50,000 numbers if you actually
know only the K numbers that you need
the six numbers that you need you're
gonna have something that was pretty
close to getting what the what
information you had so in a way there's
some form of compression that's going on
here and and what what you can do is
that those principal components you can
actually use now for regression right if
I want to regress Y on to X that's very
high-dimensional before I do this if I
don't have enough points maybe what I
can actually do is to do principal
component analysis throughout my
exercise replace them by those
compressed versions and do linear
regression on those guys and that's
called principal component regression
not surprisingly and that's something
that's pretty popular anything you can
do with K is equal to ten for example
all right so for data visualization I
did not find a Thanksgiving themed
picture but I found one that has turkey
in it get it all right and all right so
this is actually a gene data set that
was so they just so when you see
something like this you can imagine that
someone has been pre pre pre processing
the hell out of this thing this is not
like oh I could like data on 23andme and
I'm just gonna run PC on this just
doesn't happen like that and so what
happened is that so let's assume that
this was a bunch of pre-process data
which are gene expression levels so
500,000 genes among 400 1,400 Europeans
so here I actually have less
observations that I have samples and and
that's when you use principal component
regression most of the time so it
doesn't stop you and and then what you
do is you say okay I have those fifty
five hundred thousand genes among 44
hundred so here that means that there's
1,400 points here and I actually take
this 500 thousand directions right so
each person has a vector of five sites
100,000 genes that are attached to them
and I project them onto two dimensions
which should be extremely lossy right I
lose a lot of information and indeed I
do because I'm one of these guys I'm
pretty sure I'm very different from this
guy even though probably from an
American perspective we're all the same
but I think we have like slightly
different genomes and and so the thing
is now we have this so you see there's
lots of Swiss that participate in this
but actually those two principal
components recover sort of the map of
Europe I mean okay again
this is actually maybe fine grained for
you guys but you're right here there's
Portugal and Spain which are those
colors so here is color-coded and here
is Turkey of course which we know has
very different genomes right so Turks
are very at the boundary right so you
can see all the greens they stay very
far apart from everything else and then
the rest here is pretty mixed but you
know it sort of recovers if you look at
the color it sort of recovers that so
in a way those two principle components
are just a geographic feature so if you
insist on taking only two Geographic to
two suck to compress all the genomic
information of these people into two
numbers what you're actually gonna get
is longitude and latitude which you know
is somewhat surprising but not so much
if you think that it's been pre
processed all right so okay so what do
you do
beyond practice well you know you could
try to actually study those things if
you think about it for a second we did
not do any statistics I talked to you
about
iid observations but we never used the
fact that they were independent right
the way we typically use independence do
you have central de meteor maybe I
mentioned the fact that the covariances
if the word Gaussian would actually give
me something which is independent we
didn't care
this was a data analysis data mining
process that we did I give you points
and you just you know put them through
the crank there was an algorithm in six
steps and you just put it through and
that's what you got now of course
there's some work which studies says
okay if my data is actually generated
from some process maybe my points are
multivariate Gaussian with some
structure on the covariance how well am
i recovering the covariance structure
and that's where statistics kicks in and
that's where we stop alright so this is
actually a bit more difficult to study
but in a way it's not entirely
satisfactory because we could work for a
couple boards and I would just basically
sort of reverse engineer this and find
some models under which it's a good idea
to do that alright and what are those
models where those are the models that
sort of give you sort of prominence
directions that you want to find and it
will say yes if you have enough
observations you will find those
direction along which your data is
elongated okay so that's essentially
what you want to do okay so that's
exactly what this thing is telling you
so where does the statistics lie from
well everything remember so actually
that's where Elena was confused the idea
was to say well if
I have a true covariance matrix Sigma
and I never really have access to it I'm
just running PCA on the empirical
covariance matrix
how do those results relate right and
this is something that you can study so
for example if n goes to infinity and
the say and the size of your and the
size of your the the number of points
your dimension is fixed then s goes to
Sigma in any sense you want maybe each
entry is going to each entry of Sigma
for example so s is a good estimator we
know that the empirical variance is a
consistent estimator and if D is fixed
sexually not an issue so in particular
if you run PCA on the sample covariance
matrix you look at say V 1 then V 1 is
going to converge to the largest eigen
vector of Sigma as n goes to infinity
but for defects and that's you know
that's a story that we know since the
60s
more recently people are started
challenging this because what's
happening when you fix the dimension and
let the sample size go to infinity
you're certainly not allowing for this
right it's certainly not explaining to
you anything about the fact when D is
equal to 500,000 and n is equal to 14
because when these fixed and n goes to
infinity in particular and is much
larger than D which is not the case here
and so when n is much larger than D
things go well but if D is less than n
it's not clear what happens in
particularly if these of the order of n
what's happening so there's an entire
theory in mathematics that's called
random matrix theory that studies the
behavior of exactly this questions what
is the behavior of the spectrum the
eigenvalues and the eigenvectors of a
matrix in which i put random numbers and
I let so think the matrix I'm interested
in here is the matrix of X's when I
stack all my X's next to each other so
that's a matrix of size say D by n right
so each column is of size D it's one
person and so I put them and when I let
the matrix go to infinity Alice both
both D and n go to infinity but I want
the aspect ratio D over N to go to some
constant that's what they do all right
and what's nice is that in the end you
have this constant let's go
gamma that shows up in all the
asymptotics and then you can replace it
by the Oberon and you know that you have
you still have a handle of both the
dimension and the sample size whereas
usually the dimension goes away as you
let and go to infinity without having
dimension cut to anything and so now
when this happens as soon as D over n
goes to a constant you can show that
essentially there's an angle between the
largest eigen vector of Sigma and the
largest eigen value of largest
eigenvector of s as an indie go to
infinity there's always an angle you can
actually write it explicitly and it's an
angle that depends on this ratio gamma
this asymptotic ratio of the over N and
so there's been a lot of understanding
how to correct how to pay attention to
this this creates some biases that were
sort of overlooked before in particular
when I do this this is not the
proportion of explained variance when N
and D are similar this is an estimated
number computed from s this is computed
from s all these guys are computed from
s so those are actually not exactly
where you want them to be and there's
some nice work that allows you to
recalibrate what this ratio should be
how can this ratio should be computed so
it's a better representative of what the
percentage of X or the proportion of
explained variance actually is all right
so then of course there's the question
of so that's when D over N goes to some
constant so the best case that that was
you know 60s these fixed n is much
larger than D and then random matrix
theory tells you well D and n are sort
of the same order of magnitude when they
go to infinity the ratio goes to some
constant think of it as being order one
to be fair it if these a hundred times
larger than n that still works and it
depends on what you think what the
infinity is at this point but I think
the random matrix Theory results are
very useful but then even in this case I
told you that the leading eigenvector of
s is actually an angle of the leading
eigen vector of right so what's
happening is that
so let's say that D over n goes to some
gamma okay and what I claim is that if
you look at so that's V 1 that's the V 1
of s and then there's the V 1 of so
there should be of size 1 as the V 1 of
Sigma then those things are gonna have
an angle which is some function of gamma
it's complicated but there's a function
of gamma that you can see there and
there's some models ok when gamma goes
to infinity which means that D is now
much larger than n this angle is 90
degrees which means that you're getting
nothing ya know right that's the
consistent the fact that is consistent
when all right so the angle is a
function D is not a constant so if these
little o of n then gamma goes to 0 and F
of gamma goes to 0 so f of gamma is a
function that so for example if I look
at so if F of gamma this is the sine of
the angle for example then it's a
function that starts at 0 and that goes
like this and but as soon as gamma is
positive it's it goes away from 0 all
right so now what happens is that so
when gamma goes to infinity then this
thing goes to a right angle which means
I'm getting just junk right this is not
my linear vector so how do you do this
well just like everywhere in statistics
you have to just make more assumptions
you have to assume that you're not
looking for the leading eigen vector or
the direction that carries the most
variance but you're looking maybe for a
special direction and that's what sparse
PCA is doing sparse PCA is saying I'm
not looking for any direction new that
carries the most variance I'm only
looking for their direction new that is
sparse think of it for example as having
a 10 nonzero coordinates right so that's
a lot of directions still to look from
to look for but once you do this
then you actually have not only there's
a few things that actually you get from
doing this the first one is you actually
essentially replace D by K which means
that n now just I'm sorry not let's say
s nonzero coefficients you replace D by
s which means that n only has to be much
larger than s for this thing to actually
work now of course you've set your goal
weaker your goal is not to find any
direction only a sparse direction but
there's something very valuable about
sparse directions is that they actually
are interpretable when I found the V
let's say that the V that I found before
was you know point two and then 0.9 and
then one point one minus point 3 minus 3
etc so that was the coordinates of my
leading eigenvector in the original
coordinate system what does it mean well
it means that if I see a large number
that means that this V is very close
right so that's my original coordinate
system it's called it II 1 and E 2 so
that's just you know 1 0 and then 0 1
then clearly from the coordinates of V I
can tell if my V is like this or it's
like this or it's like this right well I
mean should they should all be of the
same size right so so I can tell if it's
here or here or here ok depending on
like here that means I'm gonna see
something where the y-coordinate is much
shorter than the x-coordinate here I'm
gonna see something where the
x-coordinate is much larger than the
y-coordinate and here I'm gonna see
something where the x-coordinate is
about the same size of the y-coordinate
so when things starts to be bigger
you're gonna have to make choices right
what does it mean to be bigger
when these a hundred-thousand what I
mean those things have to sum the sum of
the squares of those guys have to be of
equal to 1 so they're all very small
numbers and so it's hard for you to tell
which one is a big number and which one
is a small number why would you want to
know this because it's actually telling
you that if these very close to e 1 then
that means that a 1 in the case of the
gene example that we mean that a 1 is
the gene that's very important there's
maybe there's actually just two genes
that explain those two things and those
are the genes that have been picked up
there's two genes that encode you know
geographic location and that's it
so it's very important for you to be
able to interpret what V means where it
has large values it means that maybe it
has large values for e 1 e 2 and H 3 and
it means that it's a combination of e 1
e 2 and E 3 now you can interpret
because you have only three variables to
define and so sparse PCA builds that in
sparse PCA says listen I'm gonna I'm
gonna want to have at most ten nonzero
coefficients in the rest I want to be
zero I want to be able to be a
combination of at most ten of my
original variables and now I can do
interpretation so the problem with
sparse PCA is that it becomes very
difficult to Merrick lee to solve this
problem I can write it right so the
problem is simply you know maximize the
variance u transpose say su subject -
well I wanted to have u 2 equal to 1 so
that's the that's the original PCA but
now I also want that the sum of the
indicators of the UJ that are not equal
to 0 is at most 10 this constraint is
very non convex so I can relax it to a
convex one like we did for linear
regression
but now I've totally messed up with the
fact that I could use linear algebra to
solve this problem and so now you have
to go to much more complicated
optimization techniques which are called
as semi definite programs which do not
scale well in high dimensions and so you
have to do a bunch of tricks numerical
tricks but there are some packages that
implement some heuristics or some other
things you know relief threshold alerts
of various numerical tricks that you can
do but the problem they're trying to
solve is exactly this among all
directions that I have norm one of
course because it's the direction they
have at most say ten nonzero coordinates
I want to find the one that maximizes
the empirical variance okay so
actually before let me let me just show
you this I wanted to show you an output
of PCA where people are actually trying
to do directly
there you go
so right here you see this is in woods
this is SPSS that's a statistical
software and this is an output was pre
processed by a professional not prefers
the post process right so that's
something where they ran PCA so what is
the data this is raw data about you know
you ask doctors what they think of a the
behavior of a particular sales
representative for pharmaceutical
companies pharmaceutical companies are
trying to improve their sales force and
they're asking doctors how they would
they rate what do they value about their
interaction with a sales representative
all right so basically there's a bunch
of questions one is you know offers
credible point of view on something
trends provides valuable networking
opportunities right this is one question
rate this on a scale from one to five
that was the questions and they had a
bunch of questions like this and then
they asked you know a thousand doctors
about to make those ratings and what
they want so each doctor now is a vector
of ratings and they want to know if
there's different groups of doctors what
do doctors respond to if there's
different groups then they maybe they
know that they can actually address them
separately etc and so to do that of
course there's lots of questions and so
what you want is to just first project
into lower dimensions so you can
actually visualize what's going on and
this is what was done for this right so
these are the three first principal
component that came out okay and there's
no even though we ordered the values of
the lambdas there's no reason why the
entries of V should be ordered and if
you look at the values of V here they
look like they're pretty much order
right starts at 7.00 point 784 then
you're at the point three around here
there's something that goes up again and
then you go down actually it's marked in
red every time it goes up again okay and
so now what they did is they said okay I
need to interpret those guys I need to
tell you what this is if you tell me
there's a found the principal component
that really discriminates the doctors in
two groups the the the drug company is
going to come back to you and say okay
what is this what is this characteristic
and you say oh it's actually a linear
combination of the 40 characteristics
they said well you know we don't need
you to do that right I mean it cannot be
a linear combination of anything you
didn't ask and so for that there's first
of all there's a post-processing of PCA
which says okay once I actually say
found three principal components that
means that I found that this dimension
three space right on which I want to
project my points in this space I can
pick any direction I want so the first
thing is that you do some sort of local
arrangement so that those things look
like they're increasing and then
decreasing so you just like do you just
change you rotate your coordinate system
in this three-dimensional space that
you've actually isolated and so once you
do this the reason to do that is that it
sort of makes some big sharp differences
between large and small values of the
coordinates of the thing you had and why
do you want this because now you can say
well I'm going to start looking at the
ones that have large values and what do
they say they say in depth knowledge in
technology in depth knowledge knowledge
about this thing is clearly something
that actually characterizes the
knowledge of my sales representative and
so that's something that doctors are
sensitive to that's something that
really discriminates the doctors in a
way there's lots of variance along those
things and we're at least a lot of
variance I mean doctors are separated in
terms of their experience with respect
to this all right then so what they did
is said okay all these guys some of
those they have large values but I don't
know how to interpret them and so I'm
just gonna put the first block and I'm
gonna call it medical knowledge because
all those things are knowledge about
medical medical stuff then here I didn't
know how to interpret those guys but
those guys there's a big clump of large
coordinates and they're about you know
respectful of my time listens friendly
but courteous this is all about the
quality of interaction so this block was
actually called quality of interaction
and then there was a third block which
you can tell stirs to be spreading a
little thing there's just much less of
them but this thing was actually called
fair and critical opinion and so now you
have three discriminating directions and
you can actually give him a name
wouldn't it be beautiful if all the
numbers in the grey box came nonzero and
all the other numbers came zero there
was no ad-hoc choice I mean this is
probably an afternoon of work to like
scratch out all these numbers and put
all these color codes etc right whereas
you could just have something that tells
you okay here
non zeros you know if you can actually
make a story around why this group of
thing actually makes sense such as it is
medical knowledge then good for you
otherwise you could just say I can't and
that's what's farce PC it does for you
sparse PCA output something where all
these numbers would be zero and there
would be exactly say ten nonzero
coordinates and you can turn this knob
of ten you can make it nine you know if
you're depending on what your major is
maybe you can actually go on with twenty
of them and have the ability to tell the
story about twenty different variables
and how they fit in the same group and
depending on how you feel you could it's
easy to rerun the PCA depending on the
value that you want here and so you
could actually just come up with the one
you prefer all right then so that's the
sparse PCA thing which I'm trying to
promote I mean this is not super well
spread it's a fairly new idea maybe at
most ten years old and it's not
completely well spread in in the
statistical packages but that's clearly
what people are trying to emulate
currently yes really
you see I mean okay let's say you pick
only one so that means that you would
take all your doctors
and you would have one direction which
is quality of interaction and they would
be just spread out points here okay so
there's two things that can happen the
first one is that there's the clump here
and then those are come here right that
still presents a lot of variance and
this this happens probably want to go
back in your data and see where these
people you know visited by a different
group than these people or maybe this
people have a different you know
specialty or I mean you have to look
back at you did and try to understand
why you would have different groups of
people but if it's like completely
evenly spread out then all it's saying
is that if you want to have a uniform
quality of interaction you need to take
measures on this right you need to have
this to not be discrimination and so but
I think really when it's becoming
interesting it's not when it's
completely surprised when there's a big
group here and then there's almost no
one here and then there's a big group
here and then maybe there's something
you can do and so so right those two
things actually give you a lot of
errands okay so actually maybe I'll talk
about this there's there's here this is
sort of a mixture right you have a
mixture of two different populations of
doctors right and it turns out that
principle component analysis so what is
a mixture is when you have different
population think of like two gaussians
that are just centered at two different
points and maybe they're in high
dimensions and you want to those are
clusters of people and you want to be
able to differentiate those guys if
you're in very high dimension it's gonna
be very difficult but one of the first
processing tools that people do is to do
PCA because if those things if you have
one big group here in one big group here
it means that there's a lot of variance
along the direction that goes through
the Centers of those groups and that's
essentially what happened here you could
think of this as being to blur blobs in
high dimensions but you really just
projecting them into one dimension and
this dimension hopefully goes through
the center's and so as a pre-processing
so here I'm gonna I'm gonna stop here
but PCA is not just made for you know
dimension reduction is used for mixtures
for example it's all
so used when you have graphical data
what is the idea of pca just says if i
have a matrix that seems to have low
rank meaning that there's a lot of those
lambda i's that are very small and then
I see that plus noise then it's a good
idea to do PCA on this thing any
particular people use that in networks a
lot so you take the adjacency matrix of
a graph well you sort of pre-process it
a little bit so it looks nice and then
if you have for example two communities
in there it should look like something
that has that is low rank plus some
noise and low rank means that there's
just very few nonzero it means well low
rank means this low rank means that if
you do the scree plot you will see
something like this which means that if
you throw out all the smaller ones it
should not really matter in the overall
structure and and so you can use all
this these techniques are used
everywhere these days
not just in PCA so we call it pcs
statisticians but people call the
spectral methods or SVD alright so
everyone